[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dond
life
adorable
tu te déplaces dans l'espace avec un minimum de chemin
maximum
Joy City
Light business
St quand tu traverses la rue Dieu désir
pour plus haut
[Musique]
haut pas de place pour les débutants ou les capteurs
le cœur
envoyé est laissé à
CH pas d'endroit où finir mais quelque part
pour
commencer pas besoin de demander c'est un Smooth
Operator
Smooth
Operator Smooth Operator
[Musique]
Smooth
Up Coast to Coast St jusqu'à Chicago
Winon
May à travers le
[Musique]
Nord
face à
face, c'est CL au
cas où nous ferions une boîte d'ombre et trahirions pourtant
moi qui
poursuis une licence pour aimer Assurance pour
[Musique]
maison M tous tes souvenirs changent
allez les yeux sont comme un ange mais son cœur est
froid pas besoin  pour demander qu'il est un
opérateur
lisse
opérat lisse et lisse Lisse
[Musique] D'un
océan à l'autre jusqu'à Chicago Western
May
à travers le nord et le sud
[Musique]
à l'
opérateur
lisse
Opérateur lisse opérette lisse
conversation oper fluide
[Musique]
obtenir